[Musique]
je chante faux de l'impact de la
photographie sur notre imaginaire l'île
de pâques
la première fois que j'ai vu c'est moai
ces statues de l'île de pâques c'était
sur la couverture d'archéologie j'avais
7 ans et c'est en bits vide en ont mis
plein les yeux
immédiatement j'ai voulu être tintin
grand reporter vous voyez quand un
niveau je m'appelle ni chine manque de
bol tous mes amis m'appellent
tintin j'étais mal barré mais
enfin je suis quand même arrivé à être
photojournaliste sa match ça va marcher
avant et voilà un peu plus grande
adolescente j'ai lu pierre loti
l'enseigne de vaisseau grand poète
grands écrivains de l'académie française
qui a débarqué en 1872 sur l'île de
pâques
il nous dit au milieu du grand océan
dans une région où l'on ne passe jamais
il y à une île mystérieuse et isolé
peuplé de haute statue monstrueuse son
passé demeure une énigme
est ce que ça vous fait rêver est ce que
ça vous fait rêver
et bien moi aussi théâtre c'est la bonne
non voilà la bonne scène d'exposition
les plaques tectoniques s'entrechoquent
des volcans jaillissent 3 ils vont
mettre 2 millions d'années à refroidir
les lave à se rencontrer et à former une
île 210 km² c'est à dire je vous écoute
enfin ben oui à peu près 19 km sur huit
ça fait pas un département 110 km voilà
mais cette petite terre
ce confetti un temps j'essaye de parler
juste non c'est pas ça
la voilà cette petite terre alors je
pointe
est ce que ça marche quand le choix le
petit confetti
alors je vais y aller un attention que
je ne casse pas la gueule il est là vous
le voyez à peine un petit point là au
milieu à quatre mille kilomètres de
toute terre habitée mais il a une
importance géographique est essentielle
parce qu'il est une des pointes du
triangle que l'on nomme polynésie avec
deux autres villes la nouvelle zélande
que les maoris appel lille au long nuage
blanc et l'écoutent hawaï
donc voilà la polynésie installé
vous savez entre les trois îles en fait
y'a pas photo la plus célèbre c'est
l'île de pâques
pourquoi que serait elle sans ses
statuts à peu près la même chose que
paris sans la tour eiffel alors ce petit
confetti qui a donc une grande notoriété
nous allons mettre en scène le rideau
s'ouvre sur l'acte 1 vous allez
m'accompagner au temps de charlemagne en
lan merci en l'an 800 à peu près à peu
de choses près eh bien les premiers
explorateurs débarque
comment sont ils venus ils sont venus
d'abord des gambier et des îles
marquises et à contre courant parce que
vous ne me contredirait pas si je vous
dis que c'est beaucoup plus facile de
naviguer à contre courant parce que
quand on a plus d'eau et plus de
nourriture on peut revenir beaucoup plus
vite
qu'est-ce qui les découvrent d'abord ils
n'ont aucun sextant aucune boussole
comment la victime le jour c'est la
direction de la houle
la forme des nuages et les oiseaux
migrateurs qui les guide et la nuit eh
bien ce sont les étoiles qui établissent
la cartographie que découvre-t-il une
île luxuriante
je vais y arriver un avec des dents
j'appuie sur le banc si si ah non c'est
celui-là vous avez raison les découvre
le paradis une île luxuriant que le
climat subtropical à favoriser vient dix
siècles plus tard nous sommes en 1722
l'amiral jakob vendre goven des pays bas
mandaté par la compagnie des indes
orientales cingle vers l'île de pâques
où il s'arrête par hasard ils n'y
allaient pas du tout ne savait même pas
qu'elle existait et ce 6 avril 1722 je
vous le donne en mille c'est un dimanche
c'est un dimanche de bravo
donc on va dénommé île de pâques john
van tilburgh qui est une archéologue
travaille depuis trente ans sur l'île a
eu une image formidable pour décrire ce
qui arrive aux autochtones qui voient
ces trois villes dans la baie dans
garoua c'est comme si une soucoupes
volantes la terrisse est dans votre
jardin 50 ans passe le capitaine cook
célèbre navigateur seront aussi sur
l'île de pâques
il fait un constat épouvantable c'est
comme ça il fait un constat épouvantable
la nature s'est monté très avare de ses
dons à l'égard de cette île et vingt ans
plus tard la pérouse envoyé par l'eau 15
fera le même lapérouse sera le dernier
représentant du siècle des lumières à
aborder l'île de pâques rideau rideau à
2 nous sommes au 19e siècle du paradis à
l'enfer
il n'y a qu'un pas le ciel de l'île de
pâques s'assombrit les monolithes moye
ça c'était lille ont vu le capitaine
cook et la péruse le ciel va donc
s'assombrir vous voyez qu'elle est déjà
pratiquement désertes et les monolithes
moye mythique ne suffiront pas à
protéger les passes coin des razzias
menée par les pirates venus du pérou
pour trouver des esclaves et exploiter
des mines de bois no et de l'autre côté
de tahiti les mêmes pirates ou d'autres
viennent écumer les mers pour trouver
des esclaves pour les plantations de
canne à sucre ce qui fait que le peuple
pasqua est totalement décimée seules
quelques femmes quelques vieillards ou
encore quelques enfants subsiste la
variole et la syphilis s'installe on
dénombre en 1877 111 habitants alors que
les harkis
l'homme nous disent qu'ils étaient de
10000 à 15000 c'est à ce moment là que
les missionnaires en quête de terres
vierges aydoilles facile à convertir
débarquent ils vont baptiser à tour de
bras
vous me direz une 511 mais enfin quand
même adieu au culte de l'homme oiseau
adieu aux idoles brûlé parfois confisqué
mais surtout c'est la disparition de la
mémoire qui s'est éteinte avec la
disparition des hommes seuls porteurs du
savoir les bois parlant rongo rongo ces
glyphes qui sont écrit une ligne allant
droit une ligne à l'envers comme
l'écriture étrusque dit boustrophédon
vont être brûlés mais il en restera
quelques-uns que comme par hasard vous
allez vous étonner ou les retrouve t-on
à rome dans la confrérie des frères
missionnaires de picpus où on peut
aujourd'hui encore les découvrir mais
ils n'ont pas trouvé leur champollion et
leur pierre de rosette dont cette
écriture est à jamais disparu et ce
qu'elle raconte de la religion de la mpt
dépasse courant et bien on ne le saura
jamais on les appelle aussi des bois
parlant mêlée parce qu'on n'en n'ont pas
fini avec l'horreur avec la terreur un
français de normandie qui s'appelle jean
baptiste dutroux bornier va débarquer
avec des moutons
il s'installe sur l'île de pâques se
saisit du droit de cuissage au nom qu'il
s'est données de gens onésime premier
nous avons maintenant pendant sept ans
un drapeau français qui flotte sur l'île
de pâques et le roi jean onésime premier
que fait-il
eh bien il trouve tout ce qui porte
jupon nubile ou pas
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les 2500
autochtones ont dans leur arbre
généalogique
trois générations plutôt le nom de jean
baptiste
borni le xxème siècle ne va pas être
plus clément le chili annexes
l'île de pâques et la loue à une firme
écossaise qui va y installer jusqu'à 70
mille moutons
imaginez 110 kilomètres carrés 70 mille
moutons
là où ils baissent l'herbe ne repousse
pas que deviennent les 200 250 habitants
de l'île de pâques
eh bien ils sont enfermés parce qu'ils
le volent les moutons pour se nourrir et
donc on leur fait construire un mur et
ils sont enfermés dans deux kilomètres
carrés le premier camp de concentration
du 20e siècle
ne l'oubliez pas en 1920 la dictature
militaire installé au chili envoie ses
dissidents politiques
double peine on les installe dans un
lazaret car la peste aussi s'est
installé sur l'île de pâques les
descendants malheureusement en souffrent
encore aujourd'hui
le rideau se ferme ap de 3960 notre
civilisation arrivent au galop les
américains décident d'installer sur ce
petit con fictifs au milieu du pacifique
la plus grande des pistes d'atterrissage
de tout le pacifique
en cas d'aval y ont leur navette
spatiale il faudra bien qu'elle se pose
quelque part et pas sur votre préférence
avec eux débarquent la fée électricité
et puis en nouveau dieu le dieu
or tout change alors sur l'île de pâques
aujourd'hui le paradis qu est l île de
pâques qui s'est vu décerner au début du
21e siècle titre envié de patrimoine de
l'humanité est en danger les nappes
phréatiques sont bientôt atteinte par
les déchets abandonnés il ya aujourd'hui
à peu près 2000
tueur pour 5000 habitants et 60 mille
touristes qui débarquent chaque année
n'est elle pas un lanceur d' alerte
n'était elle pas un miroir tendu qui
reflète l'écocide le suicide écologique
qui guette notre monde
refusons de n'avoir plus bientôt de
n'avoir plus bientôt que des légendes et
des mythes pour impacter nos rêves
[Applaudissements]